[Musica]
grazie
[Applauso]
credo che le parole siano molto
importanti e che dobbiamo imparare a
scegliere le parole giuste per
comunicare quello che vogliamo
raccontare le persone ad esempio quando
si parla di cambiamento climatico non è
giusto perché noi non stiamo assistendo
a un cambiamento climatico stiamo
assistendo un disastro climatico
cambiamento climatico e quando c'era il
sole viene la pioggia il disastro
climatico e quando venezia e altre cento
città finiscono due metri sotto l'acqua
e centinaia di milioni di persone devono
traslocare perché non hanno più una casa
un'altra parola che secondo me è molto
problematica è la decrescita la
decrescita felice se io sento dire
decrescita felice cosa immagino che non
mi potrò più fare la doccia con l'acqua
calda e mi incazzo
invece la realtà è che noi abbiamo
bisogno di più crescita
ma in un'altra direzione abbiamo bisogno
della crescita di più alberi abbiamo
bisogno della crescita delle
ecotecnologie abbiamo bisogno della
crescita dell'amore della solidarietà e
bisogna anche fare un po di più di sesso
perché la gente non capisce l'ambiente
perché fa una vita triste se non fa il
sesso poi non te ne frega niente del
disastro ambientale
anzi vuoi la guerra e se nucleare è
meglio
[Applauso]
riporto una buona notizia ci salveremo
dal disastro climatico
una notizia che non è arrivata sui
giornali giornali non hanno parlato del
fatto che addirittura tre anni fa
il prezzo del carbone è andato al di
sopra del prezzo dell'energia elettrica
prodotta dal sole cioè il prezzo
dell'energia elettrica prodotta dal
carbone costa di più dell'energia
elettrica prodotta dal sole dal vento
nei paesi dove c'è più solo è più lento
fra cinque anni anche in italia
arriveremo lo stesso discorso è una
rivoluzione
la questione reale è che oggi l'ecologia
conviene economicamente
noi ci siamo posti il problema di far
capire alle persone quanto è immenso lo
spreco e lo abbiamo fatto innanzitutto
creando la libera università di alcatraz
dove da 40 anni facciamo corsi di arte
che è importante per la vita e di eco
tecnologie
abbiamo trasformato alcatraz in un
centro dimostrativo delle ecotecnologie
noi produciamo più energia di quella che
consumiamo e abbiamo salvato 400 a
dicono sempre abbiamo abbiamo io sono
per la collettività poi in realtà l'ho
fatto io chi sono questi elezioni dei
miei amici i miei amici abbiamo fatto
sta roba qui comunque abbiamo salvato
404 milioni di metri quadrati di boschi
se passate vicino a perugia un po
dell'aria buona che respirate l'abbiamo
fatta noi cose concrete
[Applauso]
poi però avevamo bisogno di una
dimostrazione spettacolare
sono andato a padova e ho convinto il
sindaco zanonato a cambiare tutto il
sistema di riscaldamento e
dell'illuminazione pubblica delle strade
si è fatto questo intervento che ha
portato un risparmio di un milione e
mezzo di euro senza che il comune
tirasse fuori una lira perché parte di
questo milione e mezzo di euro andava a
pagare l'investimento e parte il comune
se lo metteva subito in tasca ma
incredibilmente questo lo abbiamo fatto
nel 2005 e mi aspettavo che poi milano
roma tutti cambiassero il sistema
dell'illuminazione pubblica del
riscaldamento non l'hanno fatto
milano e romano continua a buttare dalla
finestra 20 milioni di euro all'anno
l'hanno fatto poi a partire dal 2016
allora ci siamo arrabbiati e abbiamo
detto dobbiamo fare qualcosa di
spettacolare e ci siamo separati
dall'italia abbiamo dichiarato
l'indipendenza
siamo la libera università di alcatraz è
diventata la repubblica libera di
alcatraz e abbiamo stampato banconote
vedete queste sono le banconote della
libera repubblica di alcatraz fatte con
carta filigranata mica fotocopia e cioè
queste sono falsificare queste turismo
abbiamo le monete stampate in metallo
della libera università di alcatraz e
poi però abbiamo cercato di fare altre
iniziative divertenti con un gruppo di
studenti del liceo di lovere sul lago
d'iseo
abbiamo deciso di fare qualche cosa che
colpisce l'immaginazione facesse sapere
alla gente che vive lì che il lago
d'iseo e uno dei più inquinati d'europa
come si fa
abbiamo deciso di costruire un isola di
bottiglie di plastica mentre stavamo
discutendo come fare eccetera eccetera
abbiamo messo un fotomontaggio in rete
con lovere questo paesino con davanti
liso di bottiglie in plastica
abbiamo fatto mille condivisione in
un'ora già il risultato c'era subito una
cosa pazzesca e poi questi ragazzi hanno
costruito quest'isola quest'isola con
pannelli fotovoltaici 40 quintali di
sabbia di piante per filtrare l'acqua le
pompe gli accumulatori eccetera
beh quest'isola depura lo 0,00 0000 0001
per cento è poca roba
però raccogliendo le migliaia di
bottiglie che sono servite per fare
quest isola nelle scuole elementari
nelle scuole medie cosa è successo che i
bambini andavano a casa dice una mamma
mi devi dare la bottiglia perché il lago
d'iseo è il più inquinato uno dei più
inquinati d'europa e le mamme il minor
ago inquinato i miei bambini fanno il
bagno nell'acqua inquinata sono
incazzate le mamme ii e voi sapete che
la mamma italiana quando si incazza è un
pericolo pubblico ambulante per cui come
è successo che sono andate dai sindaci
gli ampliati per il bavero adesso le
cose stanno cambiando
dobbiamo trovare delle cose divertenti
immaginifiche strane assurde se vogliamo
smuovere la gente non spaventarla dice
del mondo è finita perché se il mondo è
finito chissenefrega
datemi più porcherie che ve le mangio
tutte
però c'è un problema in alcune
situazioni non riesce a parlare di
ecologia
allora che cosa devi puntare devi
puntare a qualche cosa che interessa
quelle persone e che fa venir voglia di
appassionarsi ad esempio gela una città
in una situazione difficilissima
sono andato nelle cinque scuole
superiori e ho detto a sti ragazzi che
volete fare nella vita
volete emigrare come hanno fatto altri
15.000 vostri concittadini perché qui
non c'è lavoro o cambiamo la situazione
ad esempio sviluppiamo il turismo avete
un sacco di tesori facciamo conoscere ai
turisti ma non è possibile che i turisti
vengono qua perché ho aperto la pagina
di google proiettata con gela immagini e
c'erano immagini di negozi bruciati auto
bruciate refurtive ricercati dalla
polizia
eccetera centro è chiaro che un turista
e dice che questa qui angela non ci vado
e che cosa ho chiesto io questi ragazzi
mi servono 100 studenti centro
studentesse che facciano un blog
individuale sulla loro passione sulla
loro vita gela così creiamo una massa di
informazioni positive che toglieranno le
informazioni negative dal dalla ricerca
di google immagini hanno aderito 383
ragazzi e ragazze in 30 giorni abbiamo
tolto tutti le immagini negative da
google immagini
se voi andate ad esso vi prego ci avete
cellulare guardate che gela immagini è
come rimini è incredibile
allora il discorso quale noi dobbiamo
mirare a cose divertenti appassionanti e
noi seguiamo la filosofia shanghai che
vi propongo anche voi cioè partiamo
dalla cosa più semplice da fare e la
realizziamo subito non mi interessa
sapere che cosa realizzerai fra un anno
mi interessa sapere cosa sei in grado di
fare oggi che funzioni subito questa è
la valle della libera università di
alcatraz dove stiamo costruendo oltre
all'università un ecovillaggio che già
era abitato e anche qui cerchiamo di
costruire delle alternative concrete per
vivere subito in maniera diversa
grazie
[Applauso]